[Música]
durante 500 años a todos nosotros como
latinoamericanos se no se implantó un
chip aquí muy profundo en el hipotálamo
verdad que básicamente nos condenó a
tener en nuestra mente la idea de que
todo lo nuevo todo lo novedoso todo lo
fantástico tiene que venir de afuera
desde los espejitos con lo que nos
encantaron y nos maravillaron los
españoles se nos dijo que todas las
cosas modernas y tecnológicas venían de
afuera así fue con los barcos con los
trenes con los vehículos con las
máquinas y todavía no hace mucho todos
nosotros íbamos a comprar melocotones en
almíbar a la frontera porque eran lo
mejor es verdad que hay importados
todavía tenemos esa concepción en
nuestra mente de que lo novedoso es de
afuera y entonces cada vez que vamos a
un evento de innovación y la industria
4.0 y demás vamos a ver al experto de
tal país que viene a enseñarnos que es
industria 4.0 que es innovación porque
siempre vemos hacia afuera y vemos muy
poco hacia adentro
pero resulta que hace unos 30 años más o
menos los años 80 un fenómeno
maravilloso
un impacto maravilloso que tuvo la
globalización fue que me puso a mí y a
todos mis compañeros de generación en
igualdad de condiciones con niños de
otros mundos
dicen que los niños no pueden
diferenciar tan fácilmente entre los 2 y
los 6 años más o menos la realidad y la
ficción entonces mi superhéroe favorito
mi robot favorito era uno que se llamaba
ironman 28 que era controlado por un
niño y yo veía ese niño controlando ese
robot fantástico en tokio
y para mí no haya ninguna diferencia
entre ese niño y mi realidad para mí yo
vivía en ese en esa realidad con ese
niño que me puso en igualdad de
condiciones me puso en igualdad de
oportunidades en un mundo irreal tal vez
para algunos pero para mí era muy real
lo cierto es que mientras yo ella hace
niño controlando el robots y haciendo
cosas fantásticas también mis padres
después de que terminado la fábula que
yo de ella vean las noticias y la
noticia más importante que pasaba año
con año en diciembre era el cierre de
cuántas cajas de banano había exportado
costa rica
80.000 cajas de banano 100 mil cajas de
banano y entonces esta era la realidad
de mis padres y yo veía eso y por dentro
yo decía o sea como dicen ahora wat aquí
que quiera ser realidad que por un lado
yo veía a mis amigos jugando con robots
y cosas fantásticas y por otro lado yo
salía y mi país lo que veía era
solamente cajas de banano
pero dichosamente hubo un momento en esa
generación que nos cambio y nos cambio
quizás de manera que ni siquiera nos
imaginamos y fue que alguien que vivía
en san ramón
empezó a consumir tortillas en el
espacio y entonces yo podía ver a mi
mamá haciendo tortillas y por otro lado
ahora sí veía las noticias y vi al
presidente de mi país hablar con un
costarricense
nuestra misma realidad en el espacio
y eso créanlo no cambia a una generación
cambia mucho una generación cambia lo
que pensamos cambia lo que sentimos
cambia nuestra expectativa de realidad
de futuro totalmente
pero eso se acompaña también de algunos
visionarios de política pública que
pusieron en las escuelas raíz del 86
imagínese en la computación empezó en
los 80s y en el 86 ya teníamos
laboratorios de computadoras en las
escuelas
y yo tuve el privilegio porque la verdad
que así es de que en mi pueblo el
ministerio de educación decidió poner un
laboratorio de computadoras y entonces
yo podía darle a de 360 una tortuguita y
me dio hgh a un círculo
quizás no era controlar el robot allá
verdad en japón y todo pero me acercaba
mucho a esa realidad me ponía en
contacto con esa realidad y además el
astronauta andaba en el espacio y
comiendo tortillas entonces esta
generación fue impactada con eso y esa
generación fue al colegio y es un
colegio lo enfrentaron a la tecnología a
windows 3.1
todo lo que usábamos de computación eran
usar jugar solitario y hacer cosas en
paint y cosas así pero nos acercaba
mucho y todos tuvimos windows 3.1 muchos
de nosotros lo tuvimos pirateado lo
reconozco pero lo cierto es que al final
todos tuvimos ese contacto con el
nacimiento de la computación
y pasó algo más todavía algo que nos
impactó todavía más y que quizás no se
aprecia como tal y es que en algún
momento cuando ya estaba saliendo del
colegio se me dijo además en los
titulares y en las noticias que venían
mis padres que el cerebro electrónico
de esos robots y esas computadoras que
se usaban en todo el mundo si van a
hacer a nivel en imagines de usted
a jim bell en si van a ser en un cafetal
que había y ahí se iban a hacer los
cerebros y lo iban a ser costarricenses
no era gente con tres cerebros que iban
a venir a hacerlo era gente
costarricense que iba a venir a hacerlo
acá
y entonces fuimos testigos de esa
realidad fuimos impactados por esa
realidad y después vimos como la
telefonía empezó y los hoteles solares
se hicieron más chiquitos cada vez se
acuerdan y después ahora se hicieron más
grandes y ahora ya la gente anda así con
el celular todo de verdad
y llegó la internet a nuestra vida y nos
cubrió a todos nos cubrió de formas que
no pueden sabemos hace 10 15 o 20 años y
empezamos a jugar con cosas en realidad
aumentada encontramos animalitos en las
calles hace poco y ahora hablamos a
través de nuestro nuestro reloj también
verdad
pero los que venimos de atrás sabemos
que eso ya existía hace algunos años
vean como mezclamos la realidad de la
ficción y cómo de dónde venimos todos
nosotros en estas generaciones
realmente venimos de una misma realidad
y como no como no si uno viene de esa
realidad como no emprender en tecnología
o sea mi mamá me preguntaba a mí yo tuve
el privilegio de poder ir a café y
no de la tercera cafetera nuncio ir a
café de verdad y mi mamá conmigo
me preguntaba una vez y ya lo recuerda
muy bien me cuenta qué
ella me dijo que quiere ser usted cuando
sea grande
y yo le dije oye científico de robots
esa carrera no existía yo creo que no
existe todavía
yo quería ser científico de robots y
entonces me dijo y que va a ser primera
pregunta que va a hacer
una máquina de cortar y estaba harto de
café
harto del parque y me hizo la segunda
pregunta que es fundamental en la
innovación y me dijo como la va a ser y
claro como yo estaba inundado de todas
las aulas que veían las 8 horas de
televisión que veía el día
yo le dije yo voy a poner los rayos
ultravioleta y un rayo no sé qué no sé
cuánto y ya cuenta la historia muy
jovial mente pero ella me hizo dos
preguntas que son fundamentales de
innovación el que le activa uno el
talento la creatividad y la imaginación
y el como lo aterriza y dice cómo lo va
a hacer y entonces después de muchos
años finalmente me puse a ser científico
de robots me puse me puse mi compañía y
junto con un montón de locos verdad
ingenieros que comparten esta misma
visión de hacer cosas en costa rica para
el mundo hacemos productos de propiedad
intelectual costarricense en industria
4.0 que no tienen nada que envidiarle a
los que vienen de alemania japón o eeuu
pero cuando yo muestro los productos
recuerden siempre que lo que estoy
recordando es a ese niño que estaba
controlando a alguien remotamente y
estaba usando esa máquina remotamente a
través de no sé qué tecnología y
entonces hemos hecho muchas cosas hemos
hecho cosas que yo le llamo cosas
mágicas
porque porque para mí cosas mágicas es
cuando el internet nos permite hacer
cosas que hace 50 años hubieran sido
vistas como brujería
o hace 100 años hubieran sido visto que
mucho sería casi verdad el poder llegar
yo y controlar aquí hoy por hoy un
sistema que está corriendo un sistema de
riesgo en guanacaste o un sistema de
aguas en nicaragua o un sistema en
méxico o en cualquier parte del mundo
desde mi celular no deja de tener un
sentido mágico si lo piensan bien es una
evolución de nuestra humanidad que ha
llegado a un nivel en el que realmente
podemos ver cosas fantásticas y todo
aquello que soñé cuando tenía 5 o 6 años
hoy se puede hacer y entonces lo hemos
hecho pero lo hemos hecho con un sentido
de impacto de propósito y nos vamos
entonces a sectores como la agrícola por
ejemplo
vean que este caso llegamos a una
empresa agrícola hectáreas miles de
hectáreas de caña miles de millones de
dólares en producción y nos encontramos
con que los sistemas de riego que están
por todas las fincas están absolutamente
desconectados
pero lo importante es que tiene una
persona y que tiene un banquito
con dos tablas con un hueco al centro
y yo pregunto para qué es
ese es mi inodoro
y esa persona está ahí porque la llaman
por un radio para que encienda apague le
dé vuelta y diga así pues si pasó algo
con el pivote de riego y tiene una
hermosa vista del valle porque no tiene
ninguna pared
entonces el inodoro está al aire libre
literalmente y eso no solamente es un
impacto para la persona persona tiene
que caminar kilómetros para poder llegar
a su punto de trabajo pero además en la
empresa no tienen ni idea de lo que está
pasando remotamente no pueden controlar
sus sistemas nosotros lo que hacemos es
agarrar esos sistemas viejos ponerle
algo inteligente que es una cajita gris
que ven por ahí y darle una experiencia
mágica y automatizar las tareas del
riego en la industria agrícola por
ejemplo para que no pensemos que esto de
industria 4.0 es solamente para verdad
para las empresas de alta tecnología y
todo lo demás no hay un montón de
aplicaciones de la vida real de nuestras
compañías autóctonas también
un ejemplo muy lindo que me enorgullece
mucho porque lo hicimos en conjunto con
el grupo y nos fuimos con una empresa
hice
de nicaragua
a ver cómo intervenimos y generamos
tecnología en el sector de agua cómo
podemos mejorar la administración del
agua en nicaragua que además es un tema
todo el tema de agua nicaragua por
calidad abastecimiento y demás y
llegamos allá y nos encontramos con esta
realidad
nos sentamos como gerente financiero y
nos dice
el problema que nosotros tenemos es que
yo creo que me están cobrando más de
electricidad de la que deberían ok ahora
ya nos sentamos con el de calidad y nos
dice nombre mi problema es esa fila que
tengo yo de gente que viene aquí a
reclamar que el agua sale con cloro y
tengo gente los hospitales reclamando
que es que el agua con cloro
nos sentamos con el de abastecimiento y
nos dice ve a mí la torta es que yo no
sé cuánta agua tengo yo tengo que mandar
a alguien y que me diga no si hay agua
en el tanque yo no sé cuánta agua tengo
y yo tengo 138 lugares con miles de
tanques y pozos y demás y yo no sé es
cómo a dónde va andar una el agua por un
lado hacia otro
me siento como el de mantenimiento nos
sentamos con el mantenimiento y nos dice
ah no
todos está bien pero realmente el
problema es que yo no sé cuánto se usan
los equipos
cada quien tenía una versión del
problema
y el gerente nos dice
el problema aquí sabe que es le voy a
explicar que es que durante 30 años
implementamos tecnología diferentes
tipos de tecnologías y primero sacamos
de una licitación y ganó una empresa
después sacamos a los 10 años otra
cuando teníamos más plática y práctica
nuestra empresa después pusimos otra y
ganó otra empresa y hoy tenemos una
ensalada y tenemos sistemas que miren
las cosas precisamente y otros que no
miden nada
nosotros lo que hicimos fue poner una
capita de internet things de sistemas
inteligentes que hablan con todos los
sistemas de diferentes marcas y arriba
hicimos la aplicación que le llamamos
smart water que es una aplicación de
gestión que soluciona los problemas de
mantenimiento de calidad de agua de
energía desde el despacho de agua
un producto hecho aquí en costa rica no
fue que lo dijimos vamos a importar lo
de allá y vamos a hacer esto ya no lo
hicimos acá y resolvimos un problema que
no es de nicaragua son problemas
latinoamericanos y hoy día queremos
llevarlo a muchos otros países en
conjunto con con elise también
otros ejemplos en la industria más
avanzada que tenemos en costa rica la
industria médica las regulaciones son
super complejas
super complicadas si un dispositivo
médico sale al mercado con un problema
ese producto le va a causar a esa
empresa el cierre del mercado
y estas empresas que necesitan tener
controles en un proceso muy particular
que es el curado de sus dispositivos
médicos en la etapa final la
esterilización
nosotros hicimos un sistema que
administra todo el proceso de
esterilizado y le da alas a la empresa
la seguridad la trazabilidad de todo lo
que pasa en el proceso de producción en
los hornos
el proceso de curado es otra vez de
temperatura si ustedes se imaginan si yo
pongo un sistema de estos en una
panadería por ejemplo si se quema el pan
si se pasa por dos grados no importa
pero aquí
si la temperatura no cumple la
especificación que la edad dice yo no
pierdo 50 dólares de pan pierdo 100 mil
dólares de producto entonces un sistema
super robusto de internet things que le
permiten a la industria médica hoy aquí
y yo solamente afuera también ya tener
sistemas inteligentes que ningún
fabricante les estaba dando en el mundo
y aquí sólo pudimos resolver casas que
tenemos la cercanía con muchas empresas
de este sector médico
y un último ejemplo
de nuestro lado
nos encontramos con unas empresas
grandes y otras pequeñas que nos dijeron
vea es que estos sistemas de internos
tings están muy bien los sistemas
industriales de industra 4.0 muy bien
pero esto es muy caro
y ocupó saber nada más si los operarios
están usando no están usando las
máquinas y si yo estoy desperdiciando la
energía y estoy votando en la energía y
si la masa y la máquina la deja
encendida y se van y yo todo es ahora
que la máquina está encendida de
almuerzo pierdo el danés y pierde la
energía entonces nos inventamos hacer
algo innovador y dijimos qué tal si
utilizamos la idea de estos relojes
inteligentes que tenemos ahora todos
conocen los fitbit sólo estos por dólar
que mide el pulso cardíaco
esa fue la inspiración nuestra y de
equipo se sentó y dijo vamos a hacer un
robot para máquinas que nada se lo
pongamos y empieza a transmitir datos
e hicimos un gol para máquinas un sensor
que mediante tecnología inteligencia
artificial y machine learning
básicamente lo que detecta son los
estados y los pulsos eléctricos por
fuera del cable de poder de la máquina y
basados en esos estados y esos pulsos le
medio el ritmo cardíaco y dice ok la
máquina está trotando bueno está
haciendo una cosa o está haciendo otra y
básicamente con eso le damos al cliente
de una vez en unas horas su máquina
entrenada su grupo de máquinas
entrenadas y un sistema que le dice
cuánta energía está botando cuánta
energía está aprovechando y qué procesos
están haciendo sus máquinas en tiempo
real
todo eso se puede hacer acá pero no sólo
somos nosotros ese impacto que tuvieron
nuestros padres en nosotros y esa
historia que les conté ha impactado a
muchos otros hay sistemas de pagos
de transporte público que no somos
nosotros hay gente haciendo de estos
compañeros de nuestra generación
haciendo este tipo de cosas y un ejemplo
que me enorgullece muchísimo fue el de
la empresa estable sin lapse que hace
unas cuantas semanas tuvo el gusto y el
orgullo y el honor de llegar y pararse
en nasdaq y ser la primera empresa
costarricense en publicarse en bolsa en
la bolsa de tecnología de napster
bien en las caras
seguro que todos veían algo más 28
son jóvenes adultos jóvenes que están
felices porque lograron innovar está en
este caso a través de implantes que
también tienen tecnología de inter en
austin y publicarse en bolsa
pero hay que ser agradecidos también
y yo lo agradezco y agradezco
especialmente al dice porque así como yo
veía a mis fábulas también desde pequeño
me impactaron en mi cabeza con
iniciático todo recuerda iniciático era
escéptico me decía ya me enseñaba
conceptos de sostenibilidad y de por qué
era importante apagar la luz ya voy a
ahorrar hay todos los recursos
desde ahí ya habían nuestros padres una
innovación inherente y de esa innovación
vivimos hoy y tenemos los réditos hoy y
todos sacamos pecho ahora cuando salen
las noticias y todos hacemos ser verdad
en el facebook porque es muy nutritivo
muy orgullosos de publicar las noticias
de que costa rica con el 98 por ciento
de su subir de eléctrico con energía
renovable
y es por eso que yo pienso estamos hoy
en el momento en las que las empresas
grandes del país dice lynn gbm todas las
que están hoy por hoy con una capacidad
instalada suficiente y fuerte tenemos la
oportunidad de generar alianzas y
consorcios para trabajar juntos y
desarrollar productos innovadores
utilizando un ecosistema de innovación
que hay hoy que es muy ágil muy flexible
muy innovador y una capacidad instalada
y comercial muy fuerte y tenemos esa
oportunidad de que asombremos al mundo
pero esta vez desde costa rica muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]